Cuando se escribe una fracción hay términos para
nombrar el número superior y el número inferior,
y estos términos son mucho más elegantes que la
palabra "número superior" y "número inferior".
Lo que los matemáticos suelen utilizar es la
palabra "numerador" para el número superior y
"denominador" para el número inferior. Y lo que
quiero hacer ahora que sabemos que el número de
arriba es el numerador de la fracción y el número
de abajo es el denominador es comparar partes de
fracciones que tengan el mismo denominador o el
mismo numerador, así que veamos este primer par.
Quiero comparar 4/7 con 3/7, y tengo 2 enteros
aquí mismo, estos son iguales y los he dividido en
séptimos, los he dividido en siete partes iguales
y quiero ver cuál es más grande: 4/7 o 3/7.
Entonces, lo que puedo hacer es completar 4/7. Voy
a seleccionar cuatro de los siete, estos son 1, 2,
3, 4, y el hecho de que al tratar de llegar a 4/7
tengo que pasar por 3/7 primero, nos da una buena
pista de que 4/7 probablemente sea más grande,
pero ahora coloremos 3/7 sólo para que podamos
comparar, entonces 1, 2, 3/7. Aquí está bastante
claro que en el lado izquierdo hemos sombreado más
en comparación con los sombreados en el lado
derecho, entonces 4/7 representa una fracción
más grande del entero que 3/7, y la forma en que
podemos establecer esa comparación matemáticamente
es con el símbolo mayor que [>], podemos escribir
4 /7 > 3/7. Ahora bien, los símbolos mayor que y
menor que [<] a veces pueden resultar confusos:
esto es mayor que [>], esto es menor que [<], y la
forma en que lo recuerdo es que el lado puntiagudo
pequeño siempre está del lado del número menor y
el lado grande abierto siempre está del lado del
número mayor. Entonces aquí el lado grande abierto
se abre hacia el 4/7, el lado pequeño puntiagudo
se abre hacia el 3/7, 4/7 > 3/7. Ahora, ¿qué
pasa con 3/7 y 3/4? Bueno, aquí tengo diferentes
denominadores, pero tengo el mismo numerador, así
que te animo a que pauses el video y que dibujes
pequeños recuadros como este, y trates de juzgar
por ti mismo cuál de estas es una fracción mayor
o representa un número mayor. Bueno, coloremos.
Entonces pensemos primero en 3/7, y de hecho ya lo
dibujamos aquí, pero puedo hacerlo muy rápido aquí
mismo, esto es 3/7, he coloreado en tres de las
siete partes iguales. ¿Y qué será 3/4? Bueno, es
1/4, 2/4 y 3/4, y entonces está bastante claro que
3/4 representa una fracción más grande del entero,
que 3/4 es más grande o que 3/7 es más pequeño.
Entonces podemos escribir que 3/7 < 3/4. Fíjate es
el mismo numerador cuando lo dividí, porque este
símbolo de fracción también podemos verlo como una
división, cuando dividimos en más partes iguales
entonces tenemos una fracción de más partes
iguales, por lo que si comparamos 3 de 7 partes
frente a 3 de 4 este es un número menor, lo cual
tiene sentido. Ahora comparemos estos dos. Tenemos
el mismo denominador, diferentes numeradores,
3/4 en comparación con 2/4. Bueno, 3/4 ya lo
hemos visto, sólo podemos sombrear tres de estos
cuartos, estos son 3/4, y luego 2/4. Bueno, sólo
tendremos dos de los cuartos 1, 2, así que 2/4 es
claramente el número más pequeño, 3/4 es el número
mayor, entonces, una vez más podemos escribir que
3/4 > 2/4. Y finalmente te animo a que pauses el
video y trates de pensar cuál es el mayor entre
2/4 y 3/6. Bueno coloremos de nuevo. Ya vimos los
cuartos, sólo tenemos que colorear dos de estos
cuartos y luego 3/6. Hemos dividido nuestro
conjunto en seis partes iguales 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, necesitamos colorear tres de ellas, y como
puedes ver estamos coloreando exactamente la misma
cantidad del entero, estas dos fracciones son
equivalentes, estas son fracciones equivalentes:
2/4 = 3/6. Y como ves aquí, en ambas está
coloreada la mitad del entero. Si tuviéramos
que dibujar el entero y dividirlo -permíteme
hacerlo en un color diferente-, si tenemos nuestro
entero y lo dividimos en dos secciones, estamos
sombreando exactamente una de las dos secciones,
entonces podrías decir que 2/4 = 3/6, y ambos
son iguales a 1/2, entonces 1/2 = 2/4 = 3/6.